[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
hello everyone how you doing my name is
pete also knows now though
here to give you a little bit of an iron
lord's podcast first look
at our game mortal shell now for people
that have never played the game before
it is a
dark souls like game where you end up
inhabiting
different bodies or shells if you will
to go
through the world and complete killing
bosses
and so on and so forth so in this first
look video i'm just going to give you a
little bit of information of
what i ended up seeing and what i ended
up enjoying about this game
and why i think you should definitely go
pick this up so
now the first thing i want to tell you
about is the gameplay portion of the
contr of the game now as you normally
play dark souls types games before you
end up
being able to wield a sword or
an axe or so on and so forth i myself
only got through uh
you know the first hour and a half or so
of the game just pretty much getting
used to the controls
and uh the gameplay on it uh was
pretty pretty smooth uh i'm not a huge
fan
of those dark soul type games but this
was actually one of the few i actually
started getting
into playing uh and i was like oh this
is actually really interesting
i said okay this move does this this
will do this this is how i counter these
people
so eventually i started understanding
the movements and
understanding how things were ending up
growing as individuals as myself as the
individual was playing
this game now the the shells from my
understanding
from other types of
members of our team is that there are a
handful of different shells each with
different abilities
um that is on lords of gaming.net if you
want to end up going to see more
information about those
and you end up having a fast show you
end up having a
more of a defensive shell and a more of
an all-rounded uh
shell now the individual one that i got
was the one that was
the first one you get when you first
enter the world and you end up
getting that first shell and then it's
the the well-rounded one
now the controllers on
the control on this was was very easy to
understand that
you only had the quick attack the the
heart attack
um you had the the regular rolls
you had the parry ability uh you ended
up having
your your hardened skill
which uh if you'll see through the
tutorial in the beginning the hardened
skill is
essentially your block so you ended up
having that to be used as your block
instead of a regular shield or
or so on and so forth so you end up
using
that to reflect damage back to the
individual
so that you are ending up being able to
follow up on attacks
and it ended up working out very well to
parry different people's abilities
and being able to open up different
combos to allow you to
to continue your combat and i thought in
the beginning that the
the time frame between re-hardening uh
to allow
you you use the skill again was too long
but after
i started playing for a little bit i was
like all right this now i understand why
they picked this time frame to to be
able to do it and uh
it was very very good and i really
really enjoyed uh
being able to to learn that as myself
now uh as for uh its replayability
the the game itself is a souls game
all right and and you know what that
means you are going to die
a lot in the hour and a half
that i died i prom i was playing i
probably died about
20 30 times because i am not really good
in these games
whatsoever but being able to go through
that and being able
to learn from my mistakes it ended up
giving me these amazing
type of interactions with my community
and being able to
have them kind of see what i was doing
wrong being like pete what are you doing
you should be going to do this what are
you doing you should be going to do that
and it was really really nice as for the
graphics of the game
they were amazing i i couldn't believe
how beautiful the world looked now
i i looked a couple of times out and and
i looked at the the waterfalls and i was
very very amazed at how beautiful
those were and i ended up looking more
towards um the the green grass
and looking towards the facial
animations and things that happened and
how are you doing i i was like wow these
this is so impressive
and that was just in the in the first
you know five ten minutes of the game
and then the the farther i started going
through the game i ended up noticing
that more and more and more uh they
took time for certain detail
now um in one of the clips that that is
in this
um in this video is that you end up
starting to fight this guy
with swords within his body and you
actually
you actually see the animation of him
grabbing the sword out of his chest
pulling it out and then being able to
just throw like a javelin right at you
and what ended up happening was you had
to learn to dodge it as
as quick as possible but the look of
that
it was so fluid and clean
it was it was it was great and then uh
eventually when you get close enough to
him
what ends up happening is he ends up
pulling both of the swords out of it out
of his body
and then he ends up using those to
attack and i said to myself i was like
this is this is
really really cool to fight this guy and
it was very impressive
um to see the animations that they had
in place
now one of the things i was not
expecting
was when he got closer to lower health
he ended up grabbing his head pulling it
off his body
and then throwing at you like a football
and
the first time i experienced it i i was
i was kind of taken back i was like
you've got to be kidding me
did this really happen did he really
just throw a football
at my head this is right with his head
at me i just couldn't believe it and
then after that you get the poison
effect
and um one thing i wanted to talk about
that poison effect was
i i took the first poison effect i was
just
i couldn't believe how long it was
sitting on my body and i was just like
oh my god
this is this is going to take forever to
get rid of i'm like i'm going to keep
taking
uh food or health and i didn't
i didn't think it was going to be one of
those things where
i was like there's got to be a place or
something that'll be able to remove the
poison
this is this is crazy and then i learned
that there was these
uh mushrooms that if you eat them they
deal poison damage to you
so i said to myself i said
now this this system in this game which
is the
familiarity system uh is something that
i've never
seen before in another game and
what that was is every time you used
a different item it allowed you
to become more familiar with that item
which gives it more additional
attributes for instance
the there is a healing
mushroom that when you take it the for
the first couple of times
and you start increasing your
familiarity with that item
you end up um getting
maximum and then it goes from it taking
uh 24 seconds to heal you and then it
takes you
12 seconds well i had a feeling that
there was
the same type of system with the
mushrooms so
what i ended up doing was i ended up
finding these mushrooms
that had had that felt the damage and i
said all right
what's going to happen when i take them
so i just started popping them
until i started getting 100 familiarity
with them
and then at that point i ended up being
immune to poison
so now those mushrooms gave me the
ability to be immune to them
so it was very very interesting to have
that different type of
twist in this type of gameplay
and uh this type of aspect of the game
which i was definitely
not expecting but um the game
was something mortal shell is just one
of these
solid type of games that you can tell
that the
development team has taken a lot of time
into
into place for that and when when you
don't have a shell on
you can see all the detail in the
person's body and
and trying to see the story that it's
going through
i didn't get into the story that much to
see what the story actually was
and eventually we're gonna be gonna dive
a little deeper in that
uh so that you know we have a little bit
of a better understanding but
it was a fantastic game i think that if
you
want a game that's going to give you a
little bit of
some type of difficulty definitely pick
up mortal shell
it is fantastic and it is great for you
to watch
so uh thank you very much for uh for
hanging out and
uh watching this video hit that
subscribe button uh
so that you know you can see when we
come up with more uh first look videos
or if you're a part of this channel
we have the iron lords podcast which is
on every single sunday
uh check the uh times uh for for that
and then on on top of that we we have
you know our king of statues which is
uh king david does his personal uh
recommendations for statues you'd like
to purchase
and you have uh you know other types of
videos too
and also make sure you go check out
lordsofgaming.net where you can find
where all of
your gaming needs to see tech talk
you're looking at new reviews for games
all those fun things
so thank you again everyone and have a
good one
foreign i felt like i was sorry enough
away
that sucks
yeah the game's called mortal shell you
are a
pretty much a a being that has no
abilities i guess you could say it's
kind of empty
and then what ends up happening is that
you find these armored pieces of armor
and they end up
going into your body and they allow you
to
turn into certain things
it gives you like certain abilities
different different stuff like that
we did some
what
he just threw his head at me
oh look what is that and i'm like oh
that's me i'll be taking that back
oh
thank you silhouette for that twitch
prime i greatly appreciate you for doing
that thank you
four months four months in a row that
was amazing
thank you thank you very much
you